Nick Jonas was only three years old when
the original Jumanji was released but he
still remembers it vividly so when he
got the call you pushed pause on the
music and instantly said yes
do you remember watching it and yeah I
first watched it on VHS I went to
Blockbuster rented it and watched it a
few times in the first week I bought it
rented it and I loved it you know and
was a huge part of my childhood it
actually gonna freak me out first couple
times I watched it you know and then the
day that I got the call that I got the
role for this it was on the TV and my
tour bus by chance so it's kind of a
serendipitous thing but I'm you know I
was thrilled when I read this script and
saw that there was some of those
nostalgic moments within it but it
really was its own Jumanji adventure
with a really great kick-ass set of
characters and a great story guys I'm so
stoked you are here you have no idea so
start backs against the wall was there
any memorable moments for you from this
film lots of memorable moments Jack and
I really hit it off yeah with some great
time on and off set and then you know
between Kevin and Dwayne and Karen it's
just a really great group I think we had
a lot of fun making the film and III do
believe that at that translate on film
you know and
people will kind of see that chemistry
which is very real and I think it just
makes everything better now Kevin's
character mousse his weakness is cake
which is my weakness I just told you
like six lists so what's your weakness
so probably also cake but but because
I'm a type one diabetic really so it's
like it really actually is a real
weakness but now I can have ketchup take
in so forth but my real weakness is you
know probably I get in my head sometimes
i overthink things you know I put too
much pressure on myself yeah yeah why I
don't know I'm not sure I shouldn't do
it look where I am in Hawaii press
junket of a movie I'm in I think it's
cool and you are our Canadian gem
because he's saying with our Shania
Twain oh yeah
[Music]
like it
[Music]
that must have been so special for you
it was very special I got to sing with
her at stagecoach
yeah earlier this year she pulled you
out Steve told me on stage that did
party for two with her and you know we
got to talking afterwards about doing
something eventually and then I over the
summertime I wrote this Christmas song
and I played it for Joe actually and I
said who do you think should do this
with me and he was like obviously should
I have like your rack so I wrote her and
she was down to do it yeah it's just
said yes said yes is the best